olá a todos
desta forma o senhor rafael no bairro
praia estava um pouco aflita representar
o nosso colega que o revólver estava a
usar um médico aqui em cima e então que
é um instrumento musical
há um claro desafio à com tantas
facilidades marina de surgir muito usada
igual
estava tão geral não é um tipo com uma
nova banda civil ligada sem recarga
obrigado meu deus
entretanto não era crime não vai ao
cinema batalha no porto e assistimos a
um filme que era o filme jerônimo
o índio é votar pela liberdade de
expressão e de seu povo e eu era nativo
americano
então o meu nome artístico é
precisamente do gerônimo do índio de
gerar linha de janeiro ter tanto gerador
de energia houve algo novo ypsilon pode
ver aí vêm de olga e em balanço
também sou professor de yoga e o roma
investir jerônimo é gerado em roma o
ramo é do mantra hindu que é o mantra
nome
depois vamos fazer um corinthians
entretanto temos aqui esse instrumento
musical que por sua vez chamas bells mas
o primeiro que surgiu no mundo
chama-se hang quantas pessoas já ouviram
falar do ranking
ou seja o hang foi criado por um casal
suíço que é o félix avalia sabe nessa
taxa e foi criado na suíça como é que
esse processo aconteceu agora vem um dos
exemplos de assistir um filme que é
pouco público e chegou um show indiano a
casa de deus na suíça e então mostrou
este instrumento musical que é um gato
da índia em que nos tocam me fazem cara
galera muito barulho
então eu iria assim que vocês
conseguiram fazer um instrumento musical
por si com isto mas com notas que nós
pudéssemos dar algo mais digamos assim
com intensidade musical que aconteceu
além deste instrumento musical girls
conseguiram criar através de um estudo
tanto estas notas
aqui temos o google ea china
aqui temos o da áfrica e também uma
grande inspiração só assistiu país
trinidad e tobago pra casa vai aparecer
aqui uma fotografia que foram criadas
pelo el e manet e foi o único
instrumento musical criado acústico
percussão no século passado
neste país trinidad e tobago entretanto
o que eu trago aqui hoje é o bells que é
um instrumento criado por luís que um
espanhol e mora em castro de aulas
entretanto existem outros instrumentos
musicais como a terra para nos estados
unidos que foi onde eu vim agora
agora vou ter um pequeno processo que é
o construir e desconstruir
como é que eu me desconstruir a chegar
aqui uma forma construída bonito vestido
agradava o que eu consigo e propor que é
grande
a grande questão e é por isto estamos
aqui e eu vivi na amazônia no brasil
petcalf e entreguei aqui em portugal
isso foi no ano de 2007
entreguei em portugal tudo que é
material em uma mochila e fugiu a
amazônia vive na amazônia quase um ano
na natureza e na lista sobrevivência
digamos assim
portanto e outros construíram a partir
daí para ser quem sou hoje
o que acontece no meio do caminho a vida
o vôo isso vai também na universidade do
porto faculdade de economia do porto
esteve também no brasil
mas se ele não terminar meu curso porque
olhava para a economia digamos assim
tentava ensinar com os melhores
professores e chato e sempre muito
fechados e se ver a nossa economia em
portugal e do mundo respira este tipo de
energia que eu deveria fazer algo na
minha vida para respirar uma outra
energia talvez uma economia mais
espiritual e então em no ano 2008
eu estava na altura tinha era pai de uma
filha com três meses à espera da mãe tem
problema nenhum é do comportamento
normal
senti uma angústia enorme trabalho era
muito frio estava casa era tudo não
tinha nada basicamente tanto os meus
pais sabiam da minha insistência teve
aconteceu em uma loja de instrumentos
musicais na altura e e eu olhava para os
instrumentos musicais como é que eu
posso pegar e que meu despacho então era
foi harmônica então toquei muito tempo
então acaba uma imensa harmônica e
basicamente pegando aqui no joel que
abriu com goku mirim é já é que é o
alimento espiritual ou seja por acaso
nos dedicarmos mais a música que é
basicamente um canal espiritual
podemos com certeza apreciar a comida de
uma outra forma massificada não encher a
barriga e não ter tantas doenças e
nutricionistas respeitando toda a gente
a condecoração ok mas sem dúvida que é
muito importante nos conectarmos com o
mundo e neste caso quem vai pro vez que
comemos muito porque existe uma
dualidade entre o homem eo mundo então
através da música nos conectamos os
mundos e eliminamos a novidade pelo
menos é assim que o expresso incluindo a
minha alma portanto estou a olhar ele
por um tempo e vou tentar
então ter tempo para tudo e eu trouxe
aqui o meu ser e foi o primeiro cd
gravado
tanto esta imagem é expressas vem eu
estou assim basicamente isso foi no
primeiro encontro desses instrumentos
musicais nos açores esta fotografia foi
tirada por um francês
o hms isto está aqui presente
fiz o meu primeiro vídeo original foi
gravado aqui em santa maria da feira
não é por acaso estou aqui agradeço e
mensagem sms e obstruído braga
o cd foi gravado em braga no bom jesus
quer quando eu ia quando era
pequenininho e para lá terá feito isso
nos pais e entretanto algumas coisas lá
em casa e descobrir ser e esquecemos o
veneno do marco paulo não sei porque se
de uma certa identificação
primeiro vou gravar agora o meu segundo
cd gravado em vinil porque eu vim agora
os estados unidos voltar para lá em
outubro e encontrei alguém no caminho
mora caiu ea procura fazer as cópias e
foi para um lugar onde alguém fazia
gravações vinil
vou gravar em vinil e agradecer essa
marca paulo porque nos ajuda
o que nos ajuda como as suas mensagens
daí vou deixar aqui uma forma
emblemática em relação a esta roupa que
eu vou dar a minha maior fã
esta roupa não sabia quem havia de dar
mas esta roupa está precisamente
conectada com instrumentos e meia e
oferecerá entende porque ela tem apoiado
o início muito e então entrego uma forma
permita chegar outro outro lugar
entretanto vou tenho mais um minuto para
viver uma coisa eu trouxe muitos xerez
gostaria imenso que todos vaz em um
celeiro de todos é todos para que assim
então um pouco a forma como miss press
e também para sentirem está o alimento
espiritual
entretanto neste vou deixar este ponto
lá fora e gostaria que viessem que
salvaram se eles quiserem deixar algum
nativo e aqui faço vou então a economia
espiritual o que meu coração consegue
dar em troca o europa que eu não sinta
um gasto mobilização 800 gostar né não
mas o investimento e para a alma e então
prescrever que o euro assim como a
comida e tudo na vida é energia porque
eu também fiquei muito na rua aqui em
portugal e muitas pessoas não ajudaram
porque foram ea senhora e foi essa
energia do era chegar à suíça
a finlândia e agora os estados unidos
porque todas aquelas pessoas não
tivessem depositado aqui eu estava lento
na rua é eu nunca tinha chegado portanto
o euro ainda dizia assim como tudo na
vida eo mecanismo do mundo é
precisamente à vontade quando nós temos
vontade de fazer e esse é um mecanismo
do mundo para o mundo quando nasceu o
euro não existia tanto que vocês queiram
fazer é possível e eu de economia para
sair a professora de yoga massagista e
agora músico porque é porque acreditei
precisamente na alma e no coração e
levantar e fazer algo
assim quem tem músicos usam luvas
eu não uso mas agora estou aqui e posso
convidar para vir aqui no entanto favor
vem vem vem aí e toca aqui toca mesmo a
tentar fazer uma emoção
vamos dar as mãos só tem poucos minutos
por isso cada vez provavelmente ficará
mais nas mãos e toda a gente respira um
pouco em conjunto porque é a nossa união
faz a força
ok cada um de nós deve ser o seu próprio
patrão e seu próprio muro e acreditar
realmente no seu sonho no seu coração
então nós respiramos todos juntos todos
juntos temos o a roma
ah ah ah ah ah ah
ae